I have so much anxiety right now I feel
like everything is different Frank
Caprio areolas reunion with Binyam
literally led her to have a panic attack
yeah it's it hey man I need a fan spam
it's melissa here we're gonna chat about
all the highlights from the latest
episode of the other way in just a
minute but first let's get into areola
Infinium these two reunited after three
months apart and I'm not sure if minions
new look is doing it for Ariella it
seems like the sparks for her are just
not there
Ben he looks totally different we
haven't seen each other in three months
and before and he had really long
dreadlocks which is what made me notice
him right away
and now he looks so skinny and he cut
his hair it's like I'm looking under
strangers it's kind of weird
well I guess that tells us that they
didn't FaceTime or video chat during
their time apart
but I like Binion's here I think it's
cute and honestly
Ariella has way more to worry about
right now Ben her man's here Binyam took
Ariela to where they'll be living with
the baby and although she is smiling on
the inside she's having a fit
that's terrible
the colors are depressing it's dark and
obviously it's leftover decorations from
whoever is renting it this bathroom
looks like something from one of the Saw
movies I can smell the molds coming from
the bathroom my mom is gonna hate this
place
and she's gonna grab me to the side I'm
good you can't live here you can't live
in these conditions with the baby am I
the only one who feels bad for billions
I mean he's so sweet well he's been so
sweet to her so far and it looks like he
tried his best but it just wasn't enough
if you were like me you probably ask
yourself why wasn't Ariela
aware of minions living conditions when
she actually stayed with him for months
at a time before well I actually had the
opportunity to ask Ariela about that and
here's what she had to say yeah so I did
did you see you know I did travel better
need yoga and we spent time together I
know that there are some standards that
are not you know the same as in the US
and I've traveled around the world I've
been to I think I'm only missing two
continents by girl it's one thing to
it's one thing to live in a place you
know everyday permanently especially
with a baby and it's another thing to
travel and rough it and I know you know
have fun you know and experience
something so to sum it up when it was
just her his living conditions were fine
but now that a baby is in the picture
she just expects him to step it up and
provide something better well speaking
of providing something better let's go
ahead and talk about Devin and ji-hoon
because I think Devin's over it but
can't you help with the new rental after
I pay everything
when I can you use the translator thing
Nidoran tango otago you go up for the
orthodontic indicator wall I know you
paid for it
no you want no you want G home Devin's
level of patience if spectacular okay it
is on a point during this episode
ji-hoon admitted to Devin that he
doesn't have any money and he's been
lying to her this entire time why do you
keep lying to me I just went to Cabo
your girl was purple I honestly wanted
you to come here first
why hang it bullet point them in a cool
song attainment the law you're gonna go
nominees on top if you're worried about
money you're gonna leave here just a few
months
I will leave when my mother leaves girl
get up out of there
she won't said it himself take a listen
she said it they came out of his mouth
alright ninety-day fans fam next week on
the other way one of my favorite couples
get it in our mondo reunite in Mexico
and it is the sweetest thing it's just
amazing that you know I'm here and that
he's on his way
made it and areolas mom doesn't hesitate
to tell Binyam that the apartment is not
going to work for her daughter I'm a
mess right now the conditions here not
safe for a baby I do not want arey to
stay alright my 90 day fans fam next
week's episode seems like a must-see but
if you miss it don't worry because here
at eats he we will make sure you stay
updated on all the latest news from our
guilty-pleasure
see you next time
[Music]